[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir le roi
philippe de belgique poursuit sa visite
historique en république démocratique du
congo mardi il a présenté ses profonds
regrets pour les exactions subies par
les congolais durant la période
coloniale sous le règne des ans de ses
ancêtres dont léopold ii dans ce journal
nous reviendrons sur cette page sombre
de l'histoire où plus de 10 millions de
congolais ont été massacrés
l'exil préoccupant des infirmières au
zimbabwe elles seraient nombreuses à
émigrer en masse vers la grande-bretagne
où on leur propose jusqu'à dix fois plus
d'argent
et des géants rouge nageant dans le
bonheur déjà dit et jazzy diop est un
sculpteur sénégalais qui communiquent à
travers son art la bienveillance et le
bonheur qu'ils aimeraient voir dans le
monde et il est notre invité de ce soir
après son succès remarqué à la biennale
des arts rencontre à la fin de ce
journal
on ouvre ce journal avec la visite du
roi des belges en république
démocratique du congo qui se poursuit il
est à lubumbashi ce mercredi il a
exprimé ses plus profonds regrets pour
les blessures les exactions les
humiliations endurées par les congolais
durant la période coloniale notamment
sur le règne de ses ancêtres léopold ii
et le roi baudouin lors anvers et cher
revient pour nous sur ce génocide oublié
où plus de 10 millions de congolais ont
été massacrés
en 1885 léopold ii puise dans sa fortune
personnelle pour acheter le congo et on
fait sa propriété privée il réduit alors
la population en esclavage forçant les
congolais à travailler dans les
exploitations d'ivoire et de caoutchouc
ceux qui refusent ou ne sont pas assez
productif ont les mains coupées
dix millions de personnes auraient ainsi
été exterminés au cours de ces trente
années de règne trois décennies durant
lesquelles léopold 2 ne mettra jamais
les pieds au congo
plus d'un siècle plus tard son
arrière-arrière-arrière petit neveu le
roi philippe cyr en visite officielle il
y exprime ses plus profonds regrets pour
les agissements de son ancêtre sans pour
autant présenter des excuses dans un
discours aux étudiants il préfére
exhorté la jeunesse congolaise à se
tourner vers l'avenir
et notre visite qui était attendu par
les congolais mais qui n'aura pas lieu
le pape françois a reporté son voyage
était prévu début juillet il devait se
rendre en république démocratique du
congo et au soudan du sud selon le
vatican le pontife souffre d'intenses
douleurs aux genoux et se déplace en
chaise roulante depuis un mois la
déception est particulièrement grand à
goma dans l'est où il devait se rendre
et rendre hommage aux victimes de
violences qui secoue la région depuis
plus de 25 ans les préparatifs étaient
pourtant déjà bien avancé écouter ces
réactions recueillies par justin kabuba
et
cheikh hamidi ma part jusqu'à courir
parce que alice et mattia takuya
n'allait quoi c'est une totale déception
il fait moins un masque on nous avait
dit qu'il allait venir et que cette
visite allait être bénéfique selon lui
rien de joie parce qu'ils ont tous
flétrir choisir je n'ai pas un hasard
facile c'était là comme signe fort
mais apprendre le nom de son programme
vraiment banal c'est une déception car
on l'attendait avec joie c'est la
première fois qu'un cabinet à gauche
mais parce que c'est la première fois en
afrique n'a pas remarqué tout un grand
message qu'il n'ait pas pu l'amener ici
chez nous nous sommes à l'époque des
guerres là où il ya des chats barre des
91 la république de moitié du congo et
le rwanda et l époque devenue avec les
messages et des réconciliations un
message de paix et messages d'amour en
tout cas nous nous sentons très tristes
surtout nous les femmes de goma nous
attendons le pape avec l'impatience
qu'avec son arrivée chez nous ça allait
nous apporter la paix nous avons
commencé à
arrêter ça l'info
on passe au zimbabwe où les infirmières
ne rêvent que d'exil sur place elles
survivent depuis des années pour un
salaire maigre des hôpitaux démunis
résultats et les migrants masse
direction la grande bretagne où elles
peuvent gagner en moyenne 10 fois plus
d'argent un cercle vicieux qui ne fait
qu'aggraver une situation déjà alarmante
les explications de laurent version
à peine sorti d'une vacation de 12
heures à l'hôpital virginia mood samoura
doit rentrer chez elle pour ouvrir sa
petite épicerie avec un salaire d'à
peine 200 dollars par mois l'infirmière
de 52 ans n'a d'autre choix que de
multiplier les petits boulots pour
subvenir aux besoins de sa famille
vu ce que je gagne actuellement je ne me
vois pas vivre une retraite confortable
manque de moyens et de personnels
qualifiés au zimbabwe l'hôpital public
est au bord du gouffre les soignants
font face à une charge de travail quatre
fois plus élevé que la normale pour un
salaire de misère un système à bout de
souffle qui pousse chaque année des
centaines de zimbabwéens à partir
travailler à l'étranger
l'année dernière près de 1800 infirmiers
ont quitté le zimbabwe principalement
pour le royaume uni un chiffre qui
représente environ 10% des effectifs du
pays pour ceux et celles qui restent cet
exode massif ne fait qu'aggraver la
situation
virginia elle aussi envisage de partir
on est épuisé c'est tout ce que je peux
dire
c'est fatigant le ratio infirmiers
patient est vraiment mauvais c'est vrai
les bêtes
afin de pallier les besoins le
gouvernement zimbabwéen s'est récemment
mise à recruter des infirmières
retraitées mais pour les soignants le
seul moyen d'empêcher la fuite des
cerveaux et de redresser un système de
santé à l'agonie
la justice britannique donne son feu
vert pour l'expulsion des migrants au
rwanda un projet controversé qui propose
de leur envoyer leur demande les
demandeurs d'asile ceci à quelques jours
des premiers départs prévus le pays hôte
a promis ceci dit de ne pas de ne pas
accueillir des migrants dans des prisons
mais leur promet aussi qu'ils pourront
rester dans le pays s'il en faisait la
demande
après le sénégal le niger a lancé des
vols spéciaux pour rapatrier les
mendiants nigérien qui font la manche à
l'étranger cette fois ci depuis le ghana
cela concerne plusieurs centaines de
ressortissants avec femmes et enfants
qui ternissent selon les officiels
l'image de leur pays à l'extérieur
correspondance à nyamina reliera tête
exactement 558 personnes qui ont été
rapatriés d'accra vers niamey mercredi
dernier lorsque ces personnes sont
arrivées sur le sol nigérien elles ont
été ramenées par les autorités
publiques nationales vers leurs régions
d'origine principalement dans les villes
de maradi et de zinder parmi ces
mendiants qui avait élu domicile au
ghana on dénombre trois cent cinquante
six mineurs sur les 558 personnes
rapatriées ce qui soulève forcément la
question d'une expatriation organisé
probablement par des trafiquants d'êtres
humains plusieurs nouvelles
investigations par les autorités
publiques ont été lancées ces derniers
mois depuis mars dernier et le premier
vol de rapatriement de mendiants un
nigérien sur le territoire national
depuis le sénégal cette fois là et pour
cause le terreau est fertile en ce
moment au niger pour la prolifération de
la mendicité 4 millions de personnes sur
le territoire national sont touchés par
une insécurité alimentaire aiguë chaque
année plusieurs milliers de nigériens
sont contraints de se rapprocher des
centres urbains alors qu'ils sont
originaires de milieux ruraux à cause de
la faim pour fuir le réchauffement
climatique ou pourra échapper à
l'insécurité et ceux qui sont le plus
touchés par la pauvreté sont tentés par
l'exil en dehors des frontières du pays
direction le burundi où un spectacle
riche en couleurs a été organisée ce
vendredi en pleine capitale à bujumbura
une soirée festive où les tambours ont
offert un spectacle hors du commun une
occasion pour les jeunes burundaise de
démontrer leur richesse culturelle il ya
peut-être une occasion effectivement de
faire rayonner notre culture à
burundaise
et comme vous le savez très bien le
temps de rouler il est très bien
reconnue au niveau mondial classé
patrimoine de l'unesco n'est ce pas donc
c'est une fierté d'abord pour notre pays
et en tant qu'ancien tambourineur pour
moi je me sens encore une fois vraiment
revigoré quand je vois le temps
burundais bat comme ça donc moi aussi on
dirait que j'ai envie ça me donne des
ailes j'envie aussi moi de prendre ce
qu'on appelle en colombie des mini show
les petites baguettes que why l'a aidé à
les battre ce carbo dans ce temps
symbolique au pays
il est né à dakar au sénégal ou très
jeune déjà il s'intéresse au dessin et à
la création mais il devient sculpteur à
paris diplômée avec les félicitations du
jury en 2001 au bozar son travail
traversée par les questions d'identité
d'exil et de violences jazzy diop merci
d'être notre invité sur le journal de
l'afrique de france 24 merci demeure
invités alors parlez nous de vous vous
avez commencé par le dessin animé le
dessin avant de changer de voie vers la
sculpture pourquoi ce changement
c'est vrai que depuis mon enfance j'ai
toujours aimé le dessin j'ai toujours
dessiné et si je suis venu à la
sculpture c'est par le dessin c'est le
dessin qui m'a mené à la sculpture c'est
qu'à un moment donné j'avais éprouvé le
besoin de de passer à autre chose il me
manquait quelque chose et ce quelque
chose en fait c'est le rapport avec
l'espace donc il a fallu que je veux
travailler avec le volume le volume et
la matière avec quelle matière en
particulier ce que vous travaillez
aujourd'hui
le plus important c'est pas tellement la
matière mais c'est plus la façon de
créer des volumes donc je peux très bien
travaillé avec des volumes enfin avec
des matières comme de la glaise comme du
plâtre les matériaux
les nouveaux matériaux dits appelé les
résines dépoli des silicones donc en
fait le sait la finalité qui compte en
fait la matière devient un moyen
d'accéder à ma faim alors donc au coeur
de votre travail il y à cette question
d'identité d'exil donc j'ai dit vous
êtes né au sénégal et vous fait à paris
depuis plusieurs années mais aussi une
invitation à aller au delà finalement de
ça et notamment de la couleur car vous
utilisez le rouge dites nous comment
aimer cette envie d'utiliser cette
couleur et que signifie tél c'est vrai
que quand j'ai commencé la sculpture je
faisais des représentations de personnes
diverses qui venaient des quatre coins
du monde des gens qui venaient d'afrique
d'asie des européens des gens d'orient
mais je me suis dit à un moment donné
mais est-ce qu'il ya pas un moyen de
représenter tous et toutes ces personnes
en une seule fois de synthétiser la
représentation humaine et la solution
que j'ai trouvée c'était de d'utiliser
la couleur que nous avons tous sous la
peau qui est la couleur de l'être vivant
l'organe ici tu es interne c'est la
couleur du sang mélangé à la couleur de
la chair et mais c'est du vivant il
s'agit pas de parler de mort et c'est
vraiment le vivant et rouge sous la peau
ouais et donc je me suis dit que ce
serait peut-être le moyen de d'évoquer
tout le monde à la fois donc pour vous
le rouge est universel en fait
absolument c'est ça alors vous êtes
sénégalais mais votre participation à la
biennale de dakar n'est pas forcément
une évidence à chaque édition dites nous
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez accepté de
participer à cette édition là en
particulier alors j'ai eu cet immense
privilège cet immense privilège d'être
invité par la biennale de dakar à
participer à ce nouveau projet ce
nouveau concept d'exposition en plein
air qui s'appelle de routes ou de rendre
tout est un mot wolof qui signifie
promenade se promener et j'ai trouvé ça
absolument génial comme idée d'offrir
à la population aux gens qui passent une
exposition en plein air
gratuite et ça agrémenté vraiment le la
promenade et c'est l'oeuvre qu'on voit
derrière nous justement comment
s'appelle ce état aurait que cette
oeuvre s'appelle no no no no no nano
pardon nanites le mot wolof pour
poissons volants et g j'ai eu l'idée de
la deûle à faire
l'idée c'était d'évoquer le ce sentiment
de liberté de libération qu'on a tous su
qu'on a tous éprouvé au sortir de cette
pandémie
de ces deux de ces règles de vie très
plastique qu'on a eu pendant deux ans
absolument et j'espère ne pas avoir
parlé trop tôt on espère alors cette
sculpture elle est à dacca et
effectivement peut-être que l'état
pourrait éventuellement l'acquérir pour
en faire bénéficier les dakarois jose
prochain 9 revoilà ce sera une des
solutions vers annecy merci beaucoup
hadji diouf d'être venu sur le plateau
merci c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce
journal de l'afrique merci à tous ceux
qui ne sont suivies de médine a choisi
laurent en passant par paris restez avec
nous car l'actualité continue sur france
[Musique]